SHE CROSSED THE DELAWARE ON A
SLICE OF TOAST.
DANA PERINO.
"THE FIVE" ."
THE WORLD IS GETTING HOTTER, AND
IT'S NOT GLOBAL WARMING.
IT'S POLITICAL TENSION DRIVEN BY
EMOTION.
IS IT?
MOST OF AMERICA ISN'T WHAT'S ON
TV.
THE SHOUTING ON CAMERA IS WHAT
ATTRACTS THE CAMERA IN THE FIRST
PLACE, SO YOU SEE MORE OF IT.
IT MAY NOT BE A BAD IDEA TO
LOWER THE TEMPERATURE.
WHY NOT A PEACE MOVEMENT OR AT
LEAST A "KEEP THE PEACE"
MOVEMENT.
LET'S ADMIT ONE KEY TRUTH.
ALMOST ALL PEOPLE WHO DISAGREE
WITH EACH OTHER I THINK THAT
THEY ARE THE GOOD GUYS.
NORM McDONALD ONCE TWEETED
"THE IDIOT SEES THE WORLD AS
VERSUS EVIL.
HAS ALWAYS BEEN A BATTLE OF GOOD
VERSUS GOOD."
EVERYONE WHO ANNOYS YOU, THEY
THINK THEY ARE RIGHT, BUT SO DO
YOU, AND THAT ANNOYS THEM.
THE SOLUTION, UNDERSTAND FIRST
THAT WE LIVE OUR LIVES WITH
DIFFERENT FILTERS.
LEASE CULTURES CLASH.
STILL, WE ALL WANT THE SAME
DURING HURRICANE HARVEY, WE SAW
DEPLORABLES AND NONDEPLORABLES
WHAT DO YOU DO IN HARD TIMES?
YOU HELP.
YOU COMPROMISE.
WHEN POSSIBLE, YOU ALWAYS
FORGIVE.
ISN'T IT A TIME FOR A PEACE
MOVEMENT BEGUN BY CONSERVATIVES?
AFTER ALL, YOU ARE THE GUYS IN
RETURN.
IF SOMEONE THINKS YOU ARE EVIL,
ALL YOU CAN DO THROUGH YOUR
ACTIONS IS PROVE THEM WRONG.
IF IT DOESN'T WORK, AT LEAST YOU
HEY, JUAN, I WANT TO GO TO YOU
FIRST.
I BELIEVE WE WERE GOING TO
CREATE SOME KIND OF REDUCTION IN
HOSTILITIES, IT'S GOT TO COME
FROM CONSERVATIVES, BECAUSE YOU
CAN'T EXPECT IT FROM THE PEOPLE
WHO ARE OUT OF POWER.
BECAUSE YOU ARE UPSET THAT YOU
ARE OUT OF POWER.
SO IT'S LIKE THE RESPONSIBILITY
OF THE PEOPLE, CONSERVATIVES,
SUPPORTERS OF TRUMP, TO EXTEND A
HAND.
DOES THAT MAKE SENSE?
I REALLY APPRECIATED, GREG.
IT SEEMS TO ME THERE IS SO MUCH
ANIMOSITY IN THE AIR, AND
EVERYBODY IS THROWING SOMETHING
BEYOND SPITBALLS AT EACH OTHER
AT THIS POINT.
SUSPECT OF THEIR MOTIVES.
LISTENING TO WHAT YOU SAID ABOUT
FOR THEMSELVES OR ADVANTAGE
THEIR FRIENDS DOING BUSINESS.
AT THAT MOMENT, I HAVE VERY
STRONG FEELINGS ABOUT SEPARATING
CHILDREN FROM FAMILIES.
I AM NOT GOING TO DENY THOSE
FEELINGS AND I DON'T WANT TO BE
SHUT UP INEXPRESSIVE MY
FEELINGS, BUT I DO THINK WE ARE
OUT OF CONTROL IN TERMS OF THE
MOCKERY, BULLYING, THE ATTITUDE
THAT SAYS YOU ARE NOT WORTHY.
YOU ARE NOT UN-AMERICAN IF
YOU'RE NOT PLAYING WITH MY TEAM.
THEY HAVE MADE POLITICS
PERSONAL, SO NOW IT'S OUR TURN.
HOW DO YOU GET OUT OF THAT THING
WHERE YOU GO LIKE, OKAY, I'M
WILLING TO BE CIVIL EVEN IF YOU
AREN'T.
IT COULD GO FOR EITHER SIDE.
>> Jesse: IT'S TOUGH TO
UNILATERALLY LAY DOWN YOUR
WEAPONS AND POLITICS BECAUSE
BRO AND EVERYBODY SAID WE NEED
TO LOWER THE TEMPERATURE, TONE
DOWN THE RHETORIC AND UNITE AS A
COUNTRY.
A YEAR LATER, HERE WE ARE IN THE
GET BACK TO BASICS.
WE ARE ALL AMERICANS.
THE THING WE DID YESTERDAY WITH
COMMON THAT WE HAVE DIFFERENT
THAN EACH OTHER.
THAT'S A GOOD THING.
AT THE SAME TIME, THERE IS A
DIFFERENCE WHEN TRUMP RETWEETS A
VIDEO OF HIMSELF BODY SLAMMING A
CNN LOGO AND SOME OF THE THINGS
THAT HAVE GONE ON ON THE LEFT.
IT WAS IN THE INAUGURATION THAT
THE LEFT FIREBOMBED THE
LIMOUSINES.
WE HAVE HAD BLACK LIVES MATTER
PEOPLE CHANT "DEATH TO COPS."
WE HAVE HAD ANTIFA SMASH NOR
WINDOWS -- STORE WINDOWS.
NANCY PELOSI HERSELF SAID THE
TAX CUTS WERE LITERALLY GOING TO
KILL PEOPLE.
I REMEMBER BACK IN THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION, A RODEO CLOWN
DRESSED UP AS PRESIDENT OBAMA
AND HE LOST HIS JOB IMMEDIATELY.
NOW A SENATE STAFFER FOR A
DEMOCRATIC SENATOR YELLED F YOU
TO THE PRESIDENT OF THE
I AM WILLING TO SAY WHEN MY SIDE
IS WRONG BUT THE OTHER SIDE
NEEDS TO BE ACCOUNTABLE TOO.
RIGHT NOW THERE IS A DIVISION IN
TACTICS GOING TO BE?
PELOSI WHO KNOW HOW TO WIN
ELECTIONS.
DEMOCRATS WIN WHEN THEY ARE
MODERATE OR PRETEND TO BE
MODERATE, AND THEY GET IT.
THEY KNOW WHEN TO CONDEMN.
THE ACTIVISTS, WHERE THE ENERGY
IS, THEY ARE OKAY AND THEY WANT
THEY LIKE THE MOB ACTION.
THAT EXCITES THEM, THEY'RE GOING
TO HAVE TO STRUGGLE WITHOUT
INTERNAL TURMOIL ALL THE WAY
THROUGH 20 THROUGH 2020 BECAUSE
RIGHT NOW, THE DIVISION IS ON
THAT SIDE AND IT'S GETTING
PRETTY UGLY.
>> Greg: AS YOU KNOW,
KIMBERLY, I AM NOT PRACTICING
BUT WE KNOW THAT THE CHRISTLIKE
WHEN JESSE TALKS ABOUT THE OTHER
SIDE THAT IS MORE HOSTILE, THE
REACTION SHOULD BE TO TURN THE
OTHER CHEEK.
DO YOU SEE THAT HAPPENING?
>> Kimberly: IT'S A VERY GOOD
DISCUSSION, A HEALTHY DISCUSSION
TO TRY TO CREATE SOME KIND OF
UNITY, SOME CIVILITY ON BOTH
SIDES.
I THINK IT'S NOT HELPFUL TO
FINGER POINT AND SAY THEY ARE
WORSE THAN THIS SIDE ET CETERA.
FURTHER DISCOURSE, THEIR
RHETORIC, THEIR CONDUCT,
EVERYONE, INCLUDING THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES.
WE LEAD INDIVIDUALLY BY EXAMPLE.
OR TURNING A WAY A FAMILY SAYING
THEY CAN'T EAT AT A PLACE OR
THINGS LIKE THAT.
IT'S TAKING UP TOO FAR.
IT'S OKAY TO HAVE A HEALTHY
DISCUSSION AND DISAGREEMENTS
ABOUT POLITICAL PHILOSOPHY OR
IDEOLOGY.
BUT WHEN IT COMES TO MAKING
DISRESPECT, I -- IT'S CONDUCT
UNBECOMING.
>> Greg: DANA, THIS IS AN
INTERNAL CONFLICT.
NO ONE IN THE WAR THINKS THEY
ARE THE BAD GUY.
IF EVERYONE THINKS THEY ARE
RIGHT, THAT THEY ARE THE GOOD
GUYS, HOW DO YOU GET THE PERSON
WHO THINKS THEY ARE RIGHT TO
ALSO SEE THAT YOU MIGHT BE
ETERNAL QUESTION?
DURING THE OBAMA ADMINISTRATION,
IT ALWAYS WAS SURPRISING HE
WHAT A PERSONAL RELATIONSHIP CAN
DO.
THERE WAS A COUPLE TIMES I THINK
THE DEMOCRATS HAD DINNER AT THE
WHITE HOUSE AND THINGS LIKE THAT
IN THIS CURRENT ADMINISTRATION
BUT TURN THE OTHER CHEEK HAS
BEEN REPLACED BY COUNTER
PUNCHING, AND IT'S SUCCESSFUL.
DO I SEE IT CHANGING?
NOT NECESSARILY, AND THE PEOPLE
REALIZE WHILE, WE ARE REALLY
CLOSE TO UNRAVELING WHAT WE
SOMETHING, AND IF YOU ARE
PRIVILEGED TO BE ON TELEVISION,
TO HAVE A CHANCE TO GIVE YOUR
OPINIONS ABOUT SOMETHING OR
DEBATE SOMETHING WITH SOMEBODY,
YOU HAVE A CHOICE IN WHAT YOU
SAY.
I ALSO DON'T WANT TO BE
RESPONSIBLE FOR OTHER PEOPLE'S
WORDS.
POLICING YOUR OWN SIDE, THERE IS
SOMETHING TO BE SAID ABOUT THAT
BUT I ALSO FEEL LIKE THAT'S A
LOT OF RESPONSIBILITY.
OUT, THE COLUMNIST WHO WROTE A
GREAT BOOK.
ORGANIZATIONS.
WE TALKED ABOUT THE FREEMASONS
THE OTHER DAY.
THINGS LIKE THAT WHERE YOU HAD
ORGANIZATIONS WHERE PEOPLE COULD
BELONG, AND NOBODY WANTS TO
REALLY BELONG TO ANYTHING
POSSIBILITIES OF GETTING PEOPLE
PEOPLE WHO BELIEVE CALLS FOR
CIVILITY ARE INCOMPATIBLE WITH
FREE SPEECH.
LIKE OKAY, WHENEVER I COME IN
AND I MARCH AND MY VOICE IS
LOUD, YOU'RE CALLING THAT
MATTERS.
IT'S LIKE YOU DON'T WANT TO HEAR
THE LOUD NOISES BUT THAT'S THE
ONLY TIME YOU LISTEN.
BUT IS THAT ALLOWING FOR TOO
MUCH?
>> Juan: NO.
WHAT ARE YOU TALKING ABOUT?
IT'S IN AMERICA.
YOU SHOULD BE ABLE TO --
>> Greg: LIKE GOING TO
SOMEBODY'S HOUSE?
>> Juan: YOU HAVE TO OPEN YOUR
EYES TO REALITY.
THERE ARE PEOPLE WHO WANT TO
PROTEST AND HAVE A LEGITIMATE
GRIEVANCE, WHICH IS ABOUT
CHILDREN OR SOME OF THE OTHER
POLICIES OF THIS ADMINISTRATION.
THE QUESTION IS HOW DO YOU
HANDLE IT?
PART OF IT HAS TO DO WITH THE
BREAKDOWN OF FACTS AND PEOPLE
SAYING WELL, I DIDN'T HEAR ABOUT
THAT.
THAT'S NOT A FACT I'M FAMILIAR
WITH THAT KIND OF THING.
PEOPLE HAVE TO GET IT STRAIGHT.
I SAW A POLL, KNOWING THEY WERE
GOING TO DISCUSS THIS, THE POLL
CIVILITY IN THE COUNTRY HAS GONE
DOWN.
TRUMP, HE HAS TO TAKE SOME
RESPONSIBILITY BUT THAT DOESN'T
MEAN THAT THE LEFT HAS BEEN SAY
SINCE HE'S DOING THAT AND ACTING
AND SAYING "LOCK HER UP" AND
THAT KIND OF STUFF, THAT WE HAVE
TO BEHAVE THAT WAY.
I THINK THERE ARE POLITICS
INVOLVED AND THERE'S A
CALCULATION.
WHEN TRUMP SAYS SOME OF THESE
VERY PROVOCATIVE THINGS, IT
STIRS UP HIS BASE.
BUT GUESS WHAT, I THINK THE
DEMOCRATS THEN COMMEND THIS
RESPONSE TO ADJUSTING WITH
INCOME OF THE DEMOCRATS HAVE TO
BE SMART NOT TO SAY YOU CAN
EXPRESS YOUR VIEWS BUT WE DON'T
WANT TO SEE THIS ATTITUDE ON THE
PART OF THE RIGHT THAT THE LEFT
IS SO CONDESCENDING AND
ARROGANT.
YOU'VE GOT TO AT SOME POINT SAY
NO, THAT'S NOT WHAT WE ARE
ABOUT.
THAT'S NOT WHO WE ARE PARENTS
>> Jesse: I THINK YOU SAW THAT
WITH PELOSI AND SCHUMER COMING
OUT AGAINST WHAT MAXINE WATERS
SAID.
RECENTLY SOMEONE BURNED A DEAD
CARCASS OF AN ANIMAL ON A TRUMP
RESTAURANT.
FOLLOWING HER ACROSS THE STREET.
GOING OUTSIDE STEPHEN MILLER'S
APARTMENT AND CHANTING
THREATENING THINGS.
WHAT YOU WERE SAYING EARLIER,
YOU SAID THIS BEFORE.
SOMETIMES YOU ASSUME THE OTHER
SIDE HAS EVIL INTENTIONS WHEN IN
POLITICAL PHILOSOPHY.
PRESIDENT TRUMP, IN THE
BEGINNING, I USED TO THINK IF
ANYONE CAN WORK WITH
PRESIDENT TRUMP, IT'S THE
DEMOCRATS.
HE SHOWED THAT.
HE WENT AGAINST RYAN AND
McCONNELL AND WENT WITH PELOSI
AND SCHUMER WHEN IT CAME TO DACA
IN THE BEGINNING.
HE IS WILLING TO REACH ACROSS
THE ISLE BUT RIGHT NOW THAT GOLF
SEEMS REALLY DEEP.
BIGGEST MISTAKES AND INCIVILITY
IS LABELING PEOPLE.
I THINK WE NOTICED THAT, EVEN IN
THE PRIMARIES, PEOPLE CALLING
EACH OTHER RINOS AND THINGS LIKE
THAT.
THE DIVISION WASN'T JUST LEFT OR
RIGHT.
IT WAS WITHIN EACH SEPARATE
DIVISION.
>> Dana: YOU ARE GOING TO HAVE
TO ACCEPT THAT BEING NICE DIDN'T
WORK, SO THIS IS WHAT WE ARE
GOING TO DO.
IT'S A NEW WORLD, NOW WE ARE
TALKING ABOUT, THERE ARE DANGERS
OF INCIVILITY BECAUSE IT COULD
LEAD TO POSSIBLE VIOLENCE.
THESE HAVEN'T GOTTEN VIOLENT
YET, THOUGH I WOULD ARGUE THAT
THE BURNING OF THE CARCASS ON
THE FRONT PORCH, YOU'RE GOING TO
THINK YOU'RE BEING ATTACKED.
WHAT DO YOU DO?
IT COULD SPIRAL OUT OF CONTROL.
WE HAVE SUCH A GIFT OF BEING
ABLE TO LIVE IN FREEDOM AND WITH
TO PRESERVE IT.
DO NOT LOSE THIS CHANCE TO HAVE
THIS REALLY GREAT, WONDERFUL
COUNTRY CONTINUE.
>> Kimberly: IT'S TRUE.
IF YOU LET IT GET AWAY FROM YOU,
YOU SEE THINGS SPIRALING OUT.
FEELS LIKE DANGEROUS TIMES IN
TERMS OF THE INCENDIARY
RHETORIC, THE ACTIONS, THE
VIOLENT PROTESTS.
NOBODY WINS WITH THAT.
>> Juan: IF THERE WAS ONE